for the pizza dough add G's to warm
water put a tablespoon of sugar and
leave to one side in a separate bowl add
sift flour make it well and add your
olive oil and yeast mixture get your
hands right in to bring it together then
knead for about 10 minutes on a floured
surface until even and smooth
put back into the bowl cover and leave
in a warm place to prove once is roughly
doubled in size not any excess air out
place back on your surface divide your
dough into four balls and simply flatten
[Music]
[Applause]
and olive oil to hot pan and putting the
pizza dough pizza is usually cooked in a
searingly hot oven but this pan cook
method works brilliantly
as the dough starts to bubble and the
place turns golden spoon over tomato
passata which is sip tomatoes
and tearing chunks of mozzarella then
simply transfer to a hot grill until
golden and bubbly finish with fresh
rosemary I love this classic combination
but you can easily adapt it and add your
own favorite topping for a perfect pizza
in minutes it's really nice Fignon Asian
but it gives that tartness to chutney
and it's sort of rich sugary spicy add
smoked paprika chili flakes and roughly
chopped almonds a squeeze of lemon and a
dash of sherry vinegar